aquí tenemos la gráfica de la función fx
y en este momento te estoy diciendo que
fx es una función exponencial se ve como
una pero es mucho mejor cuando alguien
te dice que es una función exponencial y
bueno nuestra meta en este vídeo va a
ser averiguar para qué valor de x f de x
será menos un 25 a déjame escribirlo
para que el valor de x
efe de x va a ser igual a menos 1 sobre
25 y bueno a lo mejor está sentado en
bueno observar la gráfica y decir voy a
buscarlo aquí buscar donde fx es igual a
menos 1 sobre 25 y decir bueno eso está
muy pegado al eje de las equis y dar una
aproximación pero el problema es que
está tan pegado al eje de las equis que
realmente no sabríamos si es 3 o 4 o tal
vez otro valor no estamos seguros lo
único que estaríamos
siendo es dar una mala aproximación y
seguramente estaríamos adivinando así
que en lugar de eso voy a buscar una
expresión que defina ftx ya que aquí nos
dan una cierta información y luego puedo
resolver para x así que hagámoslo bueno
como sabemos que fx es una función
exponencial entonces
efe de x va a ser de la forma fx va a
ser de la forma a que es nuestro valor
inicial lo voy a poner con este color am
que multiplica a r elevado a la x a r
elevado a nuestra potencia x y bueno
nuestro valor inicial es suficientemente
claro que será el valor que tome la
función cuando x es igual a cero porque
si x vale cero entonces era la cero
tomara el valor de uno por lo tanto efe
de cero va a ser igual
aa entonces cuánto es efe de cero
bueno pues cuando x es igual a cero si
observamos justo aquí en esta gráfica
entro
estaríamos preguntándonos por el valor
donde la gráfica se intersecta con el
eje de las 10 podemos ver que f de 0 va
a ser igual a menos 25 así que con su
respectivo color voy a poner que a va a
tomar el valor de menos 25 va a tomar el
valor de menos 25 porque cuando x 0 r
elevado a 0 me va a dar simplemente 1 y
entonces
efe de 0 va a ser igual a menos 25 de
lujo
ahora vamos a averiguar cuánto vale la
razón común y bueno hay varias formas
para hacerlo recuerda que la razón común
es la razón entre todos valores
sucesivos por ejemplo tú puedes tomarte
efe de uno y si a esto lo dividimos
entre efe de cero
bueno pues mi respuesta va a ser la
razón común y de igual manera puedes
fijarte en f2 y dividirlo entre f1 y mi
respuesta va a ser la razón común pero
para nuestra suerte
sabemos que efe de cero bueno pues esto
toma el valor de menos 25
de menos 25 y que f1 a f1 toma el valor
de menos 5 es justo lo que me dice esta
gráfica de aquí cuando x vale 1 f x vale
menos 5 entonces aquí puedo sustituir a
efe de 1 x menos 5 y entonces ahora si
puedo saber que la razón va a ser igual
a menos 5 entre menos 25 que es
exactamente lo mismo que un quito estás
de acuerdo menos entre menos me da más y
si saco quinta me va a quedar simple y
sencillamente
quinto esta va a ser mi razón común y
ahora si con esto ya podemos escribir de
una manera completa cuánto es ftx ahora
podemos decir que fx efe de x va a ser
igual a menos 25 a menos 25 que
multiplican a r a r que es un quinto un
quinto esto elevado a la potencia x esto
elevado a la potencia x y ya con esto
podemos regresar de nuevo a nuestra
pregunta original que decía para qué
valor de x f x es igual a menos 1 sobre
25 es decir queremos que esta parte de
aquí sea igual a menos 1 sobre 25 veamos
para qué valor de x se va a cumplir esta
parte que tengo aquí
esta función va a ser igual a menos 1
sobre 25
veamos queremos resolver para x estás de
acuerdo bueno lo primero que se me
ocurre es que podemos dividir todo entre
menos 25 así podemos eliminar a este de
aquí y que me quedaría bueno de este
lado me va a quedar un quinto un quinto
elevado a la potencia x y del otro lado
del otro lado que me va a quedar bueno
si dividido todo entre menos 25 esto se
va a ir y aquí aquí que me queda bueno
tengo menos 1 sobre 25 entre menos 25 en
primer lugar menos entre menos me va a
dar más y uno sobre 25 sobre 25 es lo
mismo que uno sobre 625 1 sobre 625 25
por 25 y 625
ahora bien déjame bajar un poco la
pantalla y me va a quedar lo siguiente
en primer lugar un quinto elevado
x eso es lo mismo que 1 elevado a la
equis entre 5 elevado a la equis y bueno
eso es exactamente lo mismo que uno
entre 625 ahora bien uno elevado a
cualquier potencia siempre es uno por lo
tanto puedo quitar esa equis de ahí está
x está de más así que la voy a quitar
por aquí no la necesitamos y solamente
me queda esta igualdad que tengo aquí y
bueno esto nos está diciendo que déjenme
ponerlo aquí que es 5 elevado a la equis
tiene que ser 625 5 elevado a la equis
esto tiene que ser igual a 625 a 625 y
bueno la mejor forma que se me ocurre
para resolver esto es pensar en las
potencias de 5 y ver qué potencia de 5
es igual a 625 así que vamos a hacerlo
si me fijo en las potencias de 5 por
aquí que tengo 5 elevado a la primera
potencia esto
5 ok de 5 elevado al cuadrado esto es 25
muy bien 5 elevado al cubo esto es igual
a 125 125 5 elevado de la cuarta
potencia esto es igual
125 por 5 625 de lujo ya está ya podemos
decir que el valor al cual debemos
elevar el 5 para que nos dé 625 es decir
el valor de x debe de ser 4 y entonces
ahora podemos decir que f de 4 que f de
4 esto es igual a menos 1 sobre 25 que
es lo que queríamos menos 1 sobre 25 y
ya está lo hemos logrado porque si
recordamos la pregunta inicial dice para
qué valor de x f x es igual a menos 1
sobre 25 bueno para x igual a 4 y lo
puedes comprobar aquí si tú tienes uno
y eso lo eleva a la cuarta potencia te
va a quedar uno sobre 625 y si a eso lo
multiplicas por menos 25 bueno el signo
menos se conserva y 25 entre 625 es lo
mismo que 1 sobre 25 espero que esto te
haya ayudado a aclarar un poco todo este
problema nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo